Well,
thanks again for everyone coming today.
I just want to thank our guests in our
panel here is the first we have Andy
hidden our VP and chief ethics and
compliance officer at Google who will be
hosting the panel next to him.
We have Jeffrey Brown who an
Academy Award winning director,
film producer and screenwriter.
So Jeffrey's dedicated his life to working
with organizations and an effort to
help stop trafficking and helping victims.
And one of those organizations
who works closely,
closely with is courageous girls and on
a project that is called the India and
Nepal project, which we'll be
talking more about today. Uh,
next to him we have near
Jet Nick who, um, uh,
graduated from Cambridge University
before training at the drama center in
London and sold,
she played Anita a survivor of trafficking
and as a result of her work unsold,
she's become an ambassador for children's
international international and
they're taught not traffic campaign.
And to our far right,
we have Sylvia Vasquez Lovato.
She is the founder of courageous girls.
The organization Jeffrey is
working closely with on the
India and Nepal project.
They worked to help survivors of sexual
violence and find their inner voice in
the strength. And in addition, she's
a technologist working for paypal,
helping to re humanize money
for those who need it most.
And she's an avid mountain year,
uh,
who was the first female
Peruvian to summit Mount Everest.
So thank you all for being here today. We
appreciate it. Uh, well can it to Andy.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank
you all for your part in the,
in the movie and in their response to the,
the,
the horrible situation that
it portrays. Um, Jeffrey,
I guess it's a broad question,
but how did you end up making a
movie like this? I mean, it is,
it's not obvious to me how you,
how, how these things can, how you,
and this came back. Can you talk a
little bit about that? Yeah, so my,
my dad is a pediatric epidemiologist who,
uh,
worked all over the world for
care, save the children, UNESCO.
So I grew up in many
different countries and uh,
saw children who were at risk.
And so I'd always wanted
to make a film and I,
I became a specialist that's a director
in getting young performers to do
incredible things. And so, uh,
you know, when I read this book,
I felt like this would be a really
powerful entry point for people to learn
about a terrible thing that's happening
to the world's children and that I could
bring people in with a
film to help address this.
And can you talk a little bit
about bringing people in? How many,
how'd you pull people together
to make this a reality?
So we, uh, we had many, uh,
investors who became part of this and uh,
a large group of them live in
Seattle and they actually formed a,
they came with us to India.
They went to meet the survivors.
I knew right away that the,
the way to make a true film is to
immerse everyone in the reality,
our, our crew, even on investors,
we introduced them to
children who are survivors.
And really nothing has ever changed my
life as dramatically as meeting 2000 of
these kids who had been brutalized
in brothels, in Kolkata.
And in India, in Mumbai, and,
and, uh, Kathmandu and they,
Paul and meeting these children.
I,
I, I walked in, for instance, in
sunlight into a rescue facility.
And I,
you walk by a very old guard,
tiny old guard with a
very old gun, a rifle, uh,
which is older than the guard.
And,
and then you look to your right and
you see this cage attached to a room.
And in that cage where two girls,
one was about 13 years old,
the same age as Lakshmi in the film.
And she was terrified.
The look on her face was like a wild
animal with her back against the wall,
looking for a way out. The girl sitting
next to her with slightly older,
she was maybe 15 or 16.
She had been at sunlight for a while and
she was tenderly talking to this girl.
She was saying, my name is so and so.
These are clothes that you can have.
And uh, I am, you can just call me Dee
Dee, Dee Dee and Hindi means sister.
And what she was really saying is, I'm
your family now and you can count on me.
I'm there for you and I'm
going to help you through this.
The girl who had was the young girl had
been rescued half an hour before she had
just come out of a brothel.
And I will never forget the
look on this child's face.
And I realized in that moment,
these were my kids.
I have to do something to help them.
And uh, across India, their price,
350,000 children who've been
rescued from sexual slavery.
And so the two things that I realized
after going to many of these nonprofits
that they need,
because the problem is these kids
are not going to be able to go home.
Their families won't accept them. They're
villages one except except them back.
The shame and stigma, um,
makes these kids orphans.
They are alone in the world.
And when they age out of the NGO at 18,
they have to have vocational skills and
they have to have some inner healing so
that they can have real
relationships again.
And it's almost like they die in
this process. They become numb,
they get PTSD, they don't trust
anyone. They shut down. And,
and I arrest is an amazing way
to bring them back. It's a,
it's trauma informed Yoga, new
drug. It actually comes from India.
It's an Indian yogic practice that
is being widely used in the Va.
There are now a hundred veterans who
are trained in Irs Yoga Nedra who are
deployed and training hundreds of
thousands of returning vets and they're
getting off their meds,
they're sleeping.
And we're beginning this process now
in Nepal and India with amazing women.
There are 10 women in Nepal
who are trained in art,
art therapy and these are survivors and
we're training 25 in Kolkata and Mumbai.
And these are trained,
uh,
survivors who are trained as
dance movement therapy teachers.
And so with IRS as well
as those other modalities,
they're going to reach
hundreds of thousands of these
children and young women
to help them come back from the dead,
recover their lives,
be able to sleep at night, get out
of that low self esteem, depression.
And we're also doing
vocational training work. Uh,
we're bringing vocational
training to the NGOs and we're,
and we're bringing, um, work to helping
businesses that employ survivors expand.
So those are the,
those are the two programs that I'm really
passionate about because I feel like
without the inner freedom from fear that
these kids can get from IRS and without
vocational training,
then they're not going to remain free.
They're going to remain in this
trap that they've fallen into.
Thank you. Thank you. Sophia. Can you talk
a little bit more about your role and,
and healing some of the victims?
Yes. And thank you very much.
Thank you.
Um,
so I'm a survivor of sexual violence and
I have found my healing through nature
climbing and um, you know,
sometimes things are,
it's perfect timing and I
started my organization to
try to help young survivors
on that end.
And then I had the opportunity of
meeting Jeffrey and I saw sold and I was
completely moved. So I decided to
connect traffick survivors say Nepal.
And I was there actually
the first time we screened,
sold in Nepal until like late 2014
and there was a group of about 10,
15 survivors sitting behind me and
the imagery through the whole movie,
they were crying. And when they
finish just in managing them,
they all started embracing
themselves. Um, and you know,
several of them reach out to Jeff and
told that, thank you for sharing my story.
It was really, really powerful. And so I
had the opportunity of working with them,
bringing them to base camp of Mount
Everest and actually through iris,
give them that opportunity for
them to reconnect that strength.
And I was very fortunate of seeing how
this worked for some of these young women.
Whenever dusk will be coming into light,
you would see them starting to shiver,
feeling uncomfortable. They
couldn't close her eyes. I mean,
just even the imagery of them, you
know, having a good night's sleep.
And that's what I really
started introducing to them
and he was so powerful to
see the impact that he could have.
Um,
I don't think we have the chance
to show a couple of photos,
but we were able to see,
I mean after we started working
with a small group of young women,
some of them were able to take them into
some of the shelters and that was just
really powerful. We had, but it um,
a German I risk practitioner who
was living in Kathmandu at the time.
So she was able to kind of start doing
a very basic entry level and yes,
to see the effect of what the entry
level of virus date on that just gave us
that hope. Just imagining being able
to bring these at a much larger scale,
which is exactly what we're going to
do. I mean, what we're doing right now,
I'm trying to get these three sessions
where we're bringing actually the train
the trainer of old trainers of virus.
We're bringing in a woman
who is extremely specialized.
It's going to be spending a lot of time
in Nepal and in India and just being
able to empower this.
And this is some,
it's an amazing modality that he's
got to make such a huge difference.
Thank you. So your jet, uh, first off,
an amazing data.
Thank you.
So I,
I can't imagine how you can make them
movie like this and not be affected by it.
Tell us what was the effect of
doing a film like this for you?
Yeah, well, um, I met Jeffrey, I'm
totally by chance in New York and um,
I didn't know that trafficking existed
in the way that it does and I didn't know
that modern slavery existed in the
numbers that it did. So first of all,
just meeting Jeffrey really opened my
eyes to that. And then, um, you know,
as an actor you really need
to embody characters, um,
who a lot of their time,
their experience in life is completely
different to what you've experienced. Um,
and so you have to empathize.
So when we started shooting,
before we started shooting the movie,
we actually met with survivors and um,
I met with two women who are in their
thirties and they had been trafficked when
they were 13 and 14 and they were one
of the lucky ones who actually got out
because it's such a, it's
actually a, you know,
it's a very rare story for
these girls to get out.
But I couldn't believe the
difference between them. Um,
one of them when I met her,
she was in her thirties but you
could still see the suffering.
It was just written all over her face.
And she had,
she had had children but she had gone
into sex work in order to support them
because she didn't have
any other opportunities.
Now the other woman was just
completely different. She,
I've never seen anyone shine so bright,
like I didn't know like 10 times what you
would think of movie star shines. Like,
like her eyes were sparkly. She
was smiling, she was joyous.
She was so happy to be talking to us
as actors because she knew what we were
going to be doing with this movie.
She knew that it was going to be powerful
and she did like a dance for us in a
song for us. And what they both
had in common was their strength.
Both of them were incredibly strong.
But I think what this
second woman had found,
she had married a taxi driver
who she was in love with and um,
she had had kids and I think through
life somehow she had found heating.
And that is where I
think I rest is really,
really powerful and that it can help
these girls actually find that heating so
that they can go and so that they can
flourish and to go from that level of
suffering to that much
light and brightness. I,
I just found her amazing.
Um,
but it was the strength that they
had that sort of really struck me.
And I thought that's what I
want to bring to an eater.
Like I want to bring that kind
of strength to her. So, um,
there was one day on set and
it's a really simple scene.
Like I put on makeup every day, like,
you know, like I put on clothes, like,
you know, it's just something that I do
every day. Um, and in this scene we, um,
I was forced to put up makeup on a 13
year old Lakshmi and it was the first day
that she'd been in the brothel
and I knew where she was going.
I knew what was going to happen to,
I knew where she was headed,
I knew why I was putting
this makeup on her.
And I have never ever felt so much
rage on a film set in my life.
I was incensed. It was, it's
this tiny thing. I was just
putting lipstick on a go,
but I was so angry and in that moment
the penny dropped and I was like, oh,
that's her strength.
I was like,
that is what we need to strength as
she has that fire, she has the anger,
she has that defiance and she stands
defiant until the end. You know,
even her last line in the movie,
I've always wanted to travel.
She is defined and she's sort of like
cracking and very darkly humorous joke at
the end. And, um, and I
absolutely love that about her.
So I really learned that I think that's
exactly the way we should all be in this
fight.
We should stand defiant and we should,
we should be angry and we should be
incensed by what we've seen and what you
guys have seen today.
Um,
and we should use that anger and we
should use it to really do something about
this because this can't go on.
Um,
so yeah, I think, um,
meeting Jeffrey's sort of really
changed my life and gave me some sort of
purpose, um, um, in within this cause.
And um, yeah, I've never met anyone who
works so tired to sleep against those.
So I really hope that you will all join
us in it as well and that you will feel
that way.
I can see from your eyes that you have
been affected so much by seeing the movie.
Um, so yeah, thank you for coming on a
Monday afternoon in your lunch break.
We really appreciate it.
Thank you. And it's these, the
resilience that you spoke up,
that's really what we
saw across the board.
These children and women are,
are very,
very strong and given a chance.
Uh,
they are the fearless ones that
will go forward and make change.
They will get the laws enforced. They
will become the survivor advocate leaders.
Uh, that's what's happened in the
U S and, uh, in the nonprofits.
The staff are often survivors themselves
and they're the ones helping to rescue
others and helping to heal
others and empower them.
And so it's just about really helping
them get empowered and I rest,
we'll do that.
It will liberate them insight to
step up to their full strength,
their full power.
For those of us who aren't familiar,
I rest a little bit about
what that is. So it is, um,
it is a yogic breathing
modality where you,
you breathe and you focus on different
parts of your body and it works on the
two hemispheres of the brain.
And they've done studies with the
veterans that have been using it.
And literally what happens with Traumas,
it stores in many areas of the brain,
but the brain thankfully is very elastic.
When people have PTSD,
their brain actually shrinks.
It changes shape physically and after IRS.
It relaxes and goes back to the normal,
full shape.
It, it, the contraction releases.
And what happens with Traumas,
people get stuck in fight or flight mode.
They get stuck in being hypervigilant,
always having their adrenaline on
getting triggered by all kinds of strange
things because of the
trauma that they had,
like a door closing that
might just set them off. Uh,
and IRS is a way of welcoming fear
and facing it and in a really tender,
loving way and breathing into it.
And the first instinct of all of
us is to avoid fear and avoid,
uh,
the feelings.
But what happens with
IRS is you go into them,
you let them come up and you
let them dissolve like clouds.
They just pass through ultimately.
And it's a really powerful,
simple,
tender way of healing people.
Thank you.
Any questions from the audience?
What role do you see for corporations
in supporting this cause?
What can corporations do and what can
employees do to potentially support that
too?
So there are two levels of slavery.
There are two types of slavery on
the planet. There's sex trafficking,
which happens to very young kids.
And you just saw a movie about that and
that's what we're, we're addressing.
And then there's labor trafficking.
Both need to be addressed.
Jeff and his team are working
on corporate responsibility,
making sure that slavery is not in any
of the supply chains that are bringing
products and equipment into Google.
Uh, all corporations need
to do that going forward.
They need to make sure that
their suppliers are free
of slavery in the supply
chain. So that's one very powerful
thing. The other powerful thing,
it's giving it a voice. Uh, if we can
get this, for instance, to Twitter,
Facebook,
other companies can,
that can amplify the message of modern
day slavery. That's a very powerful thing.
People mostly walking on the street do
not know that there are now 21 million or
45 million slaves on the planet earth.
Most people don't know that.
I didn't know that before.
I read this book and an option that the
next day and started getting involved in
this issue.
Now I'm very educated in this issue,
but previously I was largely ignorant.
I thought it happened to a number
of people in other countries.
I didn't know it was so prevalent in
my own country, in my own backyard.
And it's about sort of learning,
teaching yourself what it is and then
finding ways where your heart feels called
to address it.
My heart feels really called to helping
these children survivors because I feel
like they're going to be the change
makers. And we've seen that, uh,
10 survivors testified to Congress in the
u s and we have something called the t
visa, which, uh,
is a way for survivors not to be sent
back to their countries of origin.
They can remain in the u
s because of the TVS that,
because 10 survivors
testified to Congress.
So that's an example of survivor
voices making real change that,
did that answer your question
there? They're more, you know,
there are a lot of organizations,
a lot of our partners on our website,
so@themovie.com you can see they're
wonderful organizations doing great things
both domestically and in other countries.
So you just have to find out where your
heart fields called to to take action
and serve. Thanks. Um, I was curious,
what's the reaction in
India and Nepal to the film?
So you heard a little bit about Nepal.
Uh,
we showed it to about 500 people in Nepal.
ministers of government survivors.
Uh,
the laws changed after
the showing of the film.
It's much more difficult now for someone
under age to cross from Nepal and to
India. Uh, you're required
now to be with a relative, uh,
an immediate relative of your family if
you're crossing and you're under age,
but they're still government officials
that are rubber stamping a certificate
saying that this is not a 14 year old.
This is an 18 year old who is free
of her own volition to go to India.
So there's still loopholes, uh,
but it's gotten better. India,
we haven't actually brought
the film to yet. Uh,
we hope to air it on television in India.
We're translating it
into Hindi and Bengali.
We just received a grant from
a philanthropist to do that.
And we have organizations
on the ground in Nepal,
India and the western Bangol who
will take it into rural villages,
the most prevalent areas where children
are traffic from and show this film
there. And part of what we're doing
with the vocational work that we're,
that we're beginning to do as well is to
reach out into the rural villages where
the children are traffic from and do some
of the vocational work there as well.
Because the issue is,
is poverty.
And another part of it
is the inequality of,
of women to men. Um, those
two things are very much, uh,
what can make trafficking very prevalent.
And I just quickly want to add that,
you know,
one of the problems or one
of the challenges is that
for many of these girls,
the shame that happens
after they feed rescue,
sometimes they can get
back to the vintages.
So what iris is going to be able to
bring is cutting through that shame
internally through that trauma healing,
there'll be able to gather that as
strength in order to be the more stronger
advocates of what's happening. I
mean, the words coming from survivors,
it's incredibly more powerful and
the passionate that they will have.
So that's one of the abilities.
That's one of the advantages as well
that they feel has created in at least a
little bit in the fall. And we'll
have a, but in India, um, I did,
I went to a really small screening
of sold that we did as part of a film
festival in India. And, um,
uh, we're, we haven't yet,
um, translated into Hindi or
Nepali, although, and goalie,
although we're planning on doing that.
And so I went there with the English
version of the film and, uh, we had, um,
maybe around 50 to 100 women come from
the local villages in this very rural
part of India. I remember freaking
out and I was like, oh gosh,
are they getting time to stand it?
Yeah,
I was worried about how they would relate
to it because of the language barrier.
And I was sitting and I could see the
audience when I started paying the movie
and they just went boom. And um, these,
these women from these rural villages
just kind of locked into the movie.
They understood the story and at
the end of them, at the end of it,
so many of them came to me just with tears
in their eyes and they understood the
message of it.
And so in terms of raising awareness about
the issue in these rural areas where,
where girls do just get picked off,
I thought the film played really well
there and it was really powerful in the
message, reached them regardless
of the fact that it was an English.
So I think once we do get it translated,
it'll be that much more powerful as well.
And we've opened up quite a few Indian
film festivals all over the world. And uh,
the response from the Indian audience
has been really embracing. We,
we've won quite a few awards and Indian
film festivals. It's been wonderful.
Audience awards and things like that.
Uh,
we have to wrap it up because of a
livestream. So Jeffrey Nicha. Sylvia,
thank you so much. Thank you. Very
powerful brand. Amiable. Yeah.
Thank you very much.